>> HARDWICK: Any savvy Internet
user is familiar with Godwin's
law, which states that as an
online discussion progresses, it
becomes inevitable that someone
will be compared to Hitler.
And if you don't believe me,
you're worse than Hitler.
Well, now Twitter's Stephan
Heck-- watch your language-- has
coined a brand-new law even more
relevant for our horny modern
world: Brazzers' Law.
Now, if you're unfamiliar with
Brazzers, it's the wildly
popular porn site that you've
just pretended to be unfamiliar
with.
(laughter)
So, comedians, what is Brazzers'
Law?
What is it? Paul F. Tompkins.
>> Uh, Brazzers' Law comes on
after Rizzoli & Isles, right?
(laughter)
(whooping, applause)
>> HARDWICK (laughing): That's
amazing.
>> Brazzers! In my office! Now!
>> HARDWICK: All right,
all right.
What do you want, Chief?
What do you want?
(laughter, applause)
I got a hot lead.
>> A hot lead?
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, I got a hot
lead on this story.
There's no time for questions!
>> Listen.
>> HARDWICK: What?
>> There's a guy running around
the city using a lady voice.
(laughter)
>> HARDWICK: I'll find him!
I'll find him. Thank you.
(laughing): There's a guy...
Ah... ah, okay. All right.
Oh, other people have answers,
too.
Uh, Jessica.
>> Uh, yeah, it's: When God
closes a pussy, he opens a
backdoor.
>> HARDWICK: That's great.
Yes, points.
(applause, whooping)
(laughter)
Uh, closed.
Uh, Kurt Braunohler.
>> I'll always be surprised to
find out I have a smaller dick
than I thought I did.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Very good.
But you're all wrong!
Brazzers' Law states that...
Por example, this Trump
supporter tweets...
And then literally one minute
later he tweets at porn star
Sara Jay: Tits!
(laughter)
>> What? What?
>> HARDWICK: How are you
supposed to respond to that?
>> I mean, was that in response
to something?